family feud Canada just started a few
weeks ago and it already delivered one
of the all-time greatest answers on a
edition of a family feud this is going
viral right now all right no team has
reached 300 points which means were
going to sudden death give me Logan give
me
[Applause]
all right feel simple there's one
question only one answer whoever gets it
you're playing for $10,000 that's it
whoever guesses this wins the game here
we go name Popeyes favorite food show me
chicken spinach Jerry
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah place that she seems so proud of
her answer listen she knew what she was
doing she went for it while she thought
she knew it well she don't even totally
wait for the end of the question like
you just heard pop eyes just kind of
first instinct yeah I mean she was under
a lot of pressure
yeah but it's her faith when she turned
around like wait what yeah Carrie says
while I knew Jessica Simpson that was
her thing a chicken of the sea yeah how
can you get that wrong now I think it's
a generational thing
maybe I would've thought of Popeyes
Chicken I wouldn't be the first thing
that came to him you listened spinach
anyway I mean I was hoping well ya know
hope you hope so yes but I can't really
not give too much because I went and
played family through Canada when they
had like a media day right and I play
fast money and then I got my food
confused as well name a food that is
expensive shrimp
[Applause]
yes costly shrimp Red Lobster
you get 44 940 shrimp right now dollars
[Applause]
it's tough because I think seafood came
out mine so I was trying to think
quickly of like you were saying there
were you just like mine was racing out
of here five questions in 25 seconds so
it's fast so that's the thing it's like
you Lily you're trying to figure
something in a second like it's the
first thing that comes to mind so I get
you I get where she was going with it's
another thing when you're sitting at
home is like a reflection we need to get
in here Jerry you need to get in here we
need to do a full zero if you Canada
family feud against each other
Regan says I would have said shrimp as
well thank you and also I said it could
be like if you're buying 40 pounds of
shrimp that's pretty expensive yeah be
like here's the answer with a caveat
like it's it's the answer that says that
Kerry sink caviar yeah so caviar was a
member everyone answer yeah I notice his
chicken of the sea is about 15 years old
yeah but it's still funny G she says she
should be banned from the family to
further noticed it's harsh she's I don't
disagree that's hard you understand
where she's coming from without answer
but it just happened her reaction and
also the family's reaction the moment
she said it right the family all knows
what the answer is and she's like so
confident and you dig the camera cuts
and they're just like yeah at least like
when I said shrimp I knew is a bad
answer after so she was very confident
chicken
you should have got the money now joy
founded anything food is expensive yeah